à tous ceux qui prédisaient notre
disparition notre fracturation notre
évaporation du paysage politique et bien
nous leur offrons un démenti je crois
très très net sans doute parce que
malgré la difficulté du temps malgré les
échecs que nous avons connus et qui qui
continue de peser il ne faut pas se
voiler la face nous savons résister et
rester debout et au fond pour les
parties gaulliste il n'y a là rien de
véritablement étonnant peu de parties
peuvent s'enorgueillir d'un tel niveau
de mobilisation songez que chez dans le
parti du président de la République chez
Renaissance ils ont ils sont 27000 27000
adhérents et au rassemblement national
je crois qu'ils ont été 36000 votants
donc vous voyez que on a cette force
militante qui est véritablement un atout
considérable
c'est en étant nous-même solide sur nos
convictions fidèles à notre histoire
constant sur notre vision de la France
que nous pourrons reconstruire il faut
et Francis doivent savoir qu'une autre
politique est possible et que nous
pouvons être la solution
l'état de la France apprécie deux
quinquennat est préoccupants le constat
est amère on ne peut s'en satisfaire il
nous faut réagir de ne pas accepter le
déclin croire aux ressources de notre
pays et à la combativité des Français à
condition me semble-t-il qu'on leur
propose un cap qu'ils aient une
espérance et qu'on leur tienne un
discours de vérité nous sommes le parti
de l'humain nous nous faisons de la
politique avec les gens avec nos
compatriotes on fait pas de la politique
avec des chiffres on fait pas de la
politique avec des cabinets de conseil
lorsqu'on me dit
la droite elle est au pouvoir non la
droite n'est pas au pouvoir
plus de dettes plus de dépenses
publiques plus d'immigrations plus
d'insécurité
pour de donner que quelques exemples ça
n'est évidemment pas la politique que
nous conduitions si nous étions aux
affaires alors évidemment notre
difficulté c'est que nous ne sommes pas
dans la provocation nous ne sommes pas
dans la démagogie nous sommes pas dans
la surenchère nous ne sommes pas dans la
vocifération et tout ça c'est plus
audible c'est plus audible que la
position de responsabilité c'est pas
parce que le Président de la République
est affaibli que nous nous devons
contribuer à l'affaiblissement des
institutions ça ça n'est pas possible ça
n'est pas dans notre logique ce n'est
pas dans notre ADN c'est la raison pour
laquelle sur tous les projets de loi
sénateurs et députés s'efforce de faire
des propositions utiles crédibles censé
responsable et ça je pense que cette
musique là qui est compliqué à faire
entendre et les la seule voie de la
responsabilité possible je souhaite que
nous puissions écrire cette nouvelle
page de notre histoire que nous
l'écrivions tous ensemble vive les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]